la haute couture deuxième défilé de john
galliano pour le compte de la maison
christian dior dans les jardins du parc
de bagatelle au bois de boulogne à paris
en hommage à christian dior le fondateur
passionné de jardinage et de fleurs
sophie les ailes bernard cauvin du grand
spectacle nous l'a promis qu'on l'a vu
avec la collection dior
le parc de bagatelle réquisitionnés pour
l'occasion tous les mannequins les plus
au top de la situation et 6000 rose une
bagatelle justement pour enivrer les
esprits la maison n'a pas lésiné sur les
moyens pour hisser son poulain john
galliano au firmament un budget digne
d'un long métrage de cinéma et du beau
linge comme on dit ici des mi-lourds et
emmanuelle béart
monsieur dior était un grand amoureux
des jardins
j'ai trouvé plus ce serait en seulement
merveilleux mais aussi faire preuve d'un
grand respect que de faire défiler ici
ma seconde collection haute couture pour
la maison dior
galliano en bon élève puisse dans
l'héritage maison exhume le tailleur bar
berceau du new look
la silhouette qui immortalisa jamais le
style dior taille de guêpe et cou de
girafe
le trait est tiré à l'infini mais quand
il s'agit de réveiller des héroïnes à la
mata hari et cocottes de boutoir d'un
festival qui court du xviiie siècle aux
années 20 alors là nous sommes dans le
registre cher à galliano est plus dans
l'univers traditionnel de dior galliano
s'est réveillée d'humeur romantique ce
matin at il confié romantique et romane
est pourrait-on ajouter